in Westminster in the past few minutes
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
has issued a statement so all about his
evidence given to the privilege
committee and the privileged committee
reports into whether or not he misled
Parliament with uh his statements about
what was happening during lockdown and
whether or not Boris Johnson misled them
when discussing his lockdown Behavior
and the events that took place during
the pandemic Boris Johnson saying that
the Privileges committee should publish
their report and let the world judge
their nonsense he says he says they have
no excuse for delay they're absurdly
unfair rules uh do not even allow any
criticism of their findings I have made
my views clear to the committee in
writing and will do so more widely when
they finally publish Boris Johnson
they're making it clear that he expects
the Privileges committed to publish
their report as soon as possible of
course Boris Johnson quitting as an MP
on Friday ahead of that privileges
committee publishing its findings
expectation was that Boris Johnson would
have been sanctioned and would have
perhaps been suspended from Parliament
for more than 10 days meaning that a
by-election would have been triggered in
his Uxbridge and South ruislip
constituency now in relation to this
just in the past hour or so or couple of
hours rather it was made clear the
Privileges committee who we thought were
going to publish their reports uh
tomorrow said that they received a
letter in closing further
representations for Mr Johnson was
received by the committee at 11 57 PM
last night the committee is dealing with
these and will report promptly we're
expecting the Privileges committee to
report in the next day or so and not
exactly certain when but the former PM
Boris Johnson saying the privilege
committee should publish their report
and let the world judge their nonsense
he says they have no excuse for delay